c'est la première vidéo de la chaîne
contente de bouts je suis ému qui s'en
bat les couilles de quoi on va mal
aujourd'hui mais quel drame a battu
encore faire sposito en a pas marre de
faire des histoires plus perdu on va
parler des articles sur youtube un très
bon sujet respect bienveillance
cordialité seront aujourd'hui des mots
clés ok y'a plus en plus de médias qui
écrivent des articles sur les youtuber
sûrement parce que les youtuber sont
devenus des personnalités publiques et
que du coup bah il rapporte du clic aux
médias sauf que des fois les médias
parlent d'un youtuber mais pour raconter
pas grand chose
on sent qu'ils veulent jusque là quel
est le pseudo de youtube heures pour
s'armer d'un peu des gens sur leur site
par conséquent ça donne des fois des
articles dénué de tout sens ou alors des
articles extrêmement pudique l'icf un
bref ça donne ça donne un peu tout je
veux en parler aujourd'hui et pas avant
parce qu'il ya eu pas mal d'articles la
suite à ma vidéo où je parle de david
thibeault j'aimerais juste qu'on tchèque
ensemble les articles c'est incroyable
le taux de conneries qu'on peut voir
mais avant ça j'aimerais partager avec
vous un grand moment de ma vie c'est en
lorsque j'ai eu pour la première fois un
journaliste qui a parlé de moi dans un
article avec une bienveillance total
étant donné mon jeune âge de 19 ans et
ma faible expérience dans ma carrière
cet article a été publié sur l'express
est gelée découvert lorsqu on tournait
le clip on se fait un fifa avec ses
prises sur le tournage voilà je les
petits pots sur mon téléphone et je vois
ça parce que les gens se mettent à en
parler sur twitter alors je me dis
innocemment pas joué on parle de moi et
tout ça va être sympa il a dû découvrir
un peu le phénomène des gens qui se
filment en jouant à des jeux il a dû
trouver ça cool il a dû montrer comment
ça fait évoluer c'est faux
squeeze lusine à cliquer bon un peu
péjoratif quand même de dire usine alors
que c'est juste un gars 19 ans qui
suivent en train de jouer à des jeux
vidéo mais ok et afrique mais calme toi
adrien t'énerver là alors j'avais oublié
ce geste d'heure je me tais les a sur la
tempe pour des yo tout le monde je
l'avais oubliée et ses cheveux aussi il
me manque un peu
c'est la nouvelle poule aux oeufs d'or
de youtube max et emme en rabaissant
direct genre je suis la petite chose de
youtube quoi tu la petite [ __ ] de
youtube mais arrête le jeune squeeze
tout juste 18 ans s'est imposé ces
derniers mois comme le podcasteurs
français le plus regardé de france
est ce que je fais des podcasts non ces
vidéos ont été lus pas moins de 70
une fois le mois écoulé c'est plus que
rémi gaillard norman eco est derrière ce
succès se cache une mécanique bien
huilée
en voici les rouages ah non il a dû voir
mon plant démoniaque
donc ça fou comme langue de l'article
c'est pas genre est regardée il ya des
gens qui font ça ils en vivent et en
plus ça peut générer des sommes comme ça
c'est incroyable c'est vraiment c'est
facile et c'est mal et écoute moi bien
adrien qui a écrit cet article si tu
dévoiles ma mécanique bien huilée ses
rouages je dévoilerai les tiennes
attention adrien est peut-être en train
d'enquêter sur youtube rpt mais moi je
vais enquêter sur un journaliste claqué
aussi attention un concept attrape tout
chaque phase et rabaissant chaque phrase
c'est fou d'abord spécialisé dans les
fps jeu de tir à la première personne
squeeze s'est peu à peu ouvert aux jeux
vidéo en général
un seul mot d'ordre s'amuser ça tombe
bien le jeune homme a de l'humour et de
l'énergie à revendre
donnez lui un jeu vidéo il se
débrouillera pour en tirer quelques gags
donna moore un jeu je veux faire un gars
que j'ai besoin d'un jeu sa diction
frénétique et son sens de la mise en
scène feront le reste
un maire nous avait dû mettre une vidéo
que c'était strike et elle apparaît plus
chaque épisode est en fait construit sur
le même modèle une courte introduction
face caméra une séquence de jeu
d'environ cinq minutes ponctuées de
blagues et de cris de rage puis une
brève conclusion teint mais mon gars il
a résumé le mois de l'époque
en deux phrases bravo adrien c'est bien
je sais un peu l'antithèse du zulle le
trentenaire barbu qui dissertent
philosophie autour de l'univers du jeu
vidéo la pipe à la main on sent un parti
pris ou pas on sans parti pris de
l'adria qui préfère mais foi musulmane
moi c'est sûr qu'il adore fumer la pipe
au ciad rire et ça c'est a beaucoup joué
dans son son opinion le concept en
lui-même n'a rien de novateur c'est même
un genre vu et revu très populaire et
rentable en termes de clics
c'est fou comme il diabolise un truc qui
marche genre c'est pas bien faire ce
truc là parce que ça devient populaire
et que les gens cliquent et tu gagnes de
l'argent genre parce que ça marche c'est
mal c'est nul comme réflexion le maître
reste le suédois felix valberg alias
chiodi paille
oh non
il a percé mon secret est dévoilé au
grand jour ma mécanique bien huilée ses
rouages
non squeeze a le mérite au g1 mérite
dans quelque chose attention d'avoir
copié ça que d'avoir su il importé en
france et de le revisiter à sa sauce
mieux que d'autres mieux que d'autres
tiens vous entendez ça les autres j'ai
copié mur vous aux yeux le grand gagnant
du concours de plagiat non mais c'est
vrai que c'est intéressant parce qu'à
l'époque quand tu faisais les vidéos sur
des jeux tu jouer à des jeux que
d'autres youtuber avait déjà fait en
vidéo sont accusés de les copier et même
encore aujourd'hui chez les cadets
youtuber des fois qu'ils m'envoient des
mails en me disant [ __ ] tu as joué
at-elle jeu et j'ai fait une vidéo
dessus deux semaines après et tout le
monde dit que j'te copie non le jeune
m'appartient pas et chacun va vivre des
moments différents dessus il va aborder
la chose d'une manière différente ce
n'est pas du tout du plagiaire pas du
tout sérieux et travail [ __ ] c'est ce
qui manquait sur le bulletin vraiment à
ce que ces délires face caméra pourrait
laisser entendre squeeze se révèle aussi
être un bourreau de travail selon ses
proches je ne m'attendais pas à ce qu'il
soit aussi rigoureux avant de le
connaître
confie cyprien iov cette fois que ces
2015 parce qu'aujourd'hui si pesant
retard chaque réunion je suis le mec il
savait pas que ça changerait très vite
il doit regretter vers l'indicé à
l'époque et consacre énormément de temps
à ses vidéos à sa communauté
c'est tout sauf un glandeur il a tout
juste 18 ans mais il est très mature au
niveau du travail et il le sait pas
encore mais dans moins d'un an il a
frôlé le burn out parce qu'il travaille
beaucoup trop et devient accro au stade
simon casas dans l'arctique s'est dit le
vendredi 7 novembre je leur ai envoyé un
message tellement l'article m'avait
blessé
je n'ai effectivement pas répondu à nos
demandes d'interview en vue de mauvaises
expériences que j'ai pu avoir avec les
médias si tu savais ce qui t'attend le
cas si tu savais s'il ne conteste pas
les faits présentée dans l'article génie
super souhaite apporter cette précision
sachez qu'en rien minimes le nom de mon
ancien network ne m'a aidé pour autre
chose que des problèmes administratifs
entre parenthèses quand tu as 16 ans
t'es pas forcément bien calés là dessus
n'aimant rien aider à trouver des jeux
ou des idées pour des vidéos sur ma
chaîne j'aurais plutôt content si
c'était le cas d'ailleurs c'est un
rageux monga encore plus que maintenant
incroyable mais c'est vrai mais qu'il
avait interviewé des mails du network &
network était vraiment en mode
ouais tout ce qu'il fait c'est nous les
jeux auxquels il joue chez nous qui lui
avons dit d'y jouer bref tout ce qu'il
est aujourd'hui c'est nous derrière
c'est grâce à nous tu veux être le
prochain petit gars comme lui rejoint
notre network à casteau à business man
vers eux synonyme pour y insérer j'avais
peur de tomber juste bons à près par les
partenariats pas toujours clairs et ils
n'ont pas tort l'époque mon gars
mentionné le fait que ta vidéo a été
sponsorisé ça se faisait beaucoup moins
que maintenant on voit pas trop ce
qu'est l'alimentation n'était pas hyper
clair et il ya la dgccrf qui était
arrivé et c'est une brigade de
répression des fraudes et donc de la
fraude bayal fait de faire la publicité
déguisés donc de faire de nos paies pour
une marque mais ne pas le dire et il
avait mis un coup de pression en mode
non mais les règles qui sont en place
pour la télé la radio etc s'applique
aussi à youtube vous pouvez pas faire de
doper poutre avec une marque et de
cacher le fait que la menthe vous à
payer et du coup maintenant eh ben on a
ce truc là
vous connaissez bien bref c'était whaou
on a fait du temps sur cet article 1 en
même temps il m'avait bien traumatisée à
l'époque merci adrien à l'époque avait
aussi je me souviens le site melty qui
faisait un article par vidéo que je
sortais et je sortais une vidéo par jour
et il est des articles mais jean robert
pitte à cliquer à propos de tisséo
attendait squeeze poste une vidéo de
merde ça incroyable squeeze se blesse en
testant un jeu d'horreur alors pas du
tout je m'étais juste cogné le doigt de
pied dans la vidéo puisque j'étais
j'avais acheté ses valises en ont fait
un article 1er degré c'est fou squeeze
terrorisé comme jamais découvrez
pourquoi squeeze invoque les démons et
en devient un squeeze s'attaque à un
record va-t-il survivre squeeze en mode
pervers la photo flippante squeeze
décapite des gens à la cie un vrai
psychopathe mais on dirait une news une
vraie news
ma grand-mère la loi ça elle n'est fait
un avc mais franchement je sais pas
faudrait inventer un terme pour montrer
les trucs un peu clic beit comme ça
peut-être le mot [ __ ] un clic spot pas
mal je veux pas faire le mec genre n'est
au-dessus moralisateur blabla mais
franchement on voit quand même bien
mieux que sanogo youtuber jamais on
n'oserait mentir comme ça dans notre
titre ou prêter à confusion pour ramener
des gens sur nos vidéos jamais
[Musique]
je suis un d'une histoire dans le genre
où il supprime un faux article disons
qu'il était décédé dans un accident de
voiture je sais pas quoi et il ya
vraiment des gens de sa famille qui
était tombé dessus et qu'ils avaient
appelé qui était en panique et tout en
fait je trouve un site qui écrit des
articles ya un côté vraie news il ya un
côté officiel quand il ya un titre et où
tu te dis [ __ ] même style et par
l'article tu crois au titre en fait je
sais pas comment expliquer et du coup là
c'est carrément de la désinformation
doit de faire ça c'est fou c'est
clairement pas moi qui allais faire ça
lol bon là on est dans les vieux trucs
mais tout a changé asseyez-vous bien ils
ont appris de leurs erreurs
lol la vidéo que j'ai sorti récemment
qui parle de david et de thibaut après
cette vidéo il ya pas mal de médias qui
ont écrit des articles pour parler de ce
truc là parce que forcément dès que tu
es ce que tu penses sur quelqu'un les
gens ils disent à aurillac la challe et
la baston allez vas-y mettez vous une
balayette on de voir qui va gagner et
vous savez déjà
tu pourrais me démonte vous savez déjà
arrêté je suis mal à dubaï son petit
doigt les gains pas de panique certains
médias sont arrivés et ils sont du bon
vin peut rationaliser le truc qu'on va
un petit peu calmé les gens là les gens
veulent du clash de la baston nom va
rationaliser tout ça on va calmer on va
reprendre les faits et on va détendre
tout le monde quoi dans la bienveillance
le public squeeze fracasse thibault in
shape la vidéo règlement de comptes dont
tout le monde parle à paris match
squeeze vs thibault in shape nouveau
clash dans youtube game c'est fou comme
ils ont voulu engrais n'est le truc
comme il croit qu'un affrontement des
comptes perso à régler etc mais pas du
tout c'est pas du tout où les
journalistes qu'ils ont comme ça
attention j'ai pas du tout que vous
croyez ça mais y en a pas mal tout comme
ya pas mal de youtube heures qui sont
pas très honnête non plus ils veulent
vraiment juste marquer claj drama
affrontements oh mon dieu et c'est à
cause de ça qu'il ya plein de gens qui
du coup aux pas à dire ce qu'ils pensent
aux pas parler des choses parce qu'il
savait la percussion que ça va avoir et
c'est trop triste
rires des sites amis comme nom d'arctic
thibault in shape invite squeeze sur le
ring
en fait ce qui est faux dans ses titres
c'est qu'il ya des gens qui ne clique
pas sur l'article qui le voit juste
passé et ils prennent le titre comme un
fait établi
et c'est là où il ya des informations
c'est comme une vidéo youtube ci tu
cliques pas dessus et tu lis juste le
titre il ya grave désinformation bat
c'est pareil avec les les médias qui
publient des articles sur des quais
écrit des articles sauf que eux je
trouve qu'il ya un côté très officielle
très sage devant le moc chercher ils
sont beaucoup plus crédibles ces médias
avec ses articles que
un youtube heures qui fût de saint-tite
plus ta clique on sait que c'est à
youtube elle fait un titre plus tactique
poste qui veut des vues alors qu'un
média il ya un petit côté officiel
crédit bextra et c'est encore plus
dangereux je trouve un petit boîtier
partager la vidéo clash de squeeze en
l'invitant à régler leurs comptes sur le
ring de quoi tu là ils ont pris au
premier degré le commentaire de timon
octogone direct non très bonne vidéo
chacun est en droit de penser ce qu'il
veut le mag fait une réponse pacifiste à
l'opposé du clash et ce média titre
thibault in shape invite squeeze sur le
ring c'est une dernière chose dont je
vous parlais c'est les quizz pour
attirer des gens il ya des sites qui
font des quiz des voix dans ses coups il
se retrouve des questions qui sont basés
sur un truc assez perso dont tu parle
même pas en vidéo ça fout le sommes car
compris fait au grand jour des truc
perso ça fout le sommes écoutés faisons
un coup ensemble sur mega quiz il est un
ensemble efficace
à quel âge et du clae sa première chaîne
youtube 12 ans à ces trois questions
il a le mec à travailler mais pas trop
pas trop quand même avec l uci par jay
créer une chaîne gaming
on sait combien gagnent t-il combien ce
widget il a approximativement par mois
ces fouilles genre eux mêmes savent la
réponse georis à bien les pouces allez
tout le monde sait que c'est trop humide
quoi je peux même pas avoir les
résultats mais je veux savoir combien de
cas vous allez vas-y m'inscrire les
résultats combien il gagne vous rendez
vous la manipulation ils font genre qui
savent combien je gagne et du coup si tu
veux connaître la réponse tu dois
inscrire à leur ci est donc rentré des
données persos qui utilisons pour les
ventes s'envolent de la pub ou quoi est
il faut envoyer un truc payant par
téléphone moi non mais là là en vrai là
c'est l'extrême il ya plein de sites qui
ont fait des quizz sur des youtuber et
sa part pas du tout dans ce délire la
médaille mais je suis choquée quoi on
est en train de debug qu'une arnaque bon
je vois quand même le sms que j'aimerais
bien savoir combien je gagne par mois
ces pratiques attend regarde et je crois
que c'est une énorme des sms sans
surtaxe merci de renvoyer votre sms avec
le boom mots clés je suis sûr qu'en vrai
je viens vraiment payé trois euros en
voyant ça mais ils font jour que ça n'a
pas marché et donc je vais renvoyer le
code et vont reprendre 3 euros et ad
j'ai essayé avec trois écritures
différentes à temps mais ça veut dire je
viens de perdre neuf balles sénat
renâcle mais je suis débile
[ __ ] mais ça on s'en fout c'est pas ça
le pire le pire c'est qu'on saura jamais
combien squeeze gagnes tu désolé alors
y'en a un autre surprise point business
que c'est payant cette fois non trente
questions tout la verse de l'eau
beaucoup trop long il est né le 27
janvier 96 ces animaux c'est ces animaux
c'est de dolbeau et charline aux petites
questions sur la petite amie tiens on
dévoile la vie privée on y va au moins
d'abonnés mars 2018 il en a 36 après un
bad buzz il a tout perdu en quelle année
est il apparu sur youtube aux pokémon
quoi pas d'accord je suis un pokémon
avec elle du tueur partage son studio
personne il n'a pas d'amis boîte
pourquoi at il peur de l'eau ah j'ai
peur de l'eau j'ai pas peur de l'eau
j'ai peur de la merde tu pas peur de
luis tu m'envoies de l'aude sujet pas
faire
quelle taille fait-il kouakou coup il
propose pas à mettre 70
je bats à mettre 60 ans je suis avec 70
est-ce que je suis blessé parce que je
me prends la vérité dans la face oui de
m allez hop rock l année at-il
réellement eu la barbe
seules bonnes questions du quiz 2009
j'étais très précoce squeeze écrit-il
dans ces vidéos n'ont jamais jamais 30%
de bonnes réponses alors attends il ya
deux réponses qui m'intéresse avec qui
je partage mon studio avec ma feuille
cailleteau pas du tout pas du tout
pourquoi at il peur de l'eau il s'est
noyé dans une piscine
il est mort noyé et maintenant il a peur
de l'eau bon qu'est ce qu'a pensé
corinne tavernier de squeeze il est bien
super merci corinne les amis c'est la
fin de cette vidéo sur les articles sur
les youtuber et les articles sur moi du
coup plus particulièrement j'espère que
vous avez passé un bon et doux moment à
mes côtés moi c'était le cas j'ai pris
beaucoup de plaisir
ça m'a rappelé que des bons souvenirs je
sais pas de quoi parlera la prochaine
fois mais j'adore par les différents
sujets avec vous et c'était assez
intéressant en fait de montrer la
problématique des articles plus ta
clique de la part de médias qui ont une
aura officiel d'information alors que
non c'est juste des gens en chien comme
les youtuber qui ont besoin de cliquer
pour survivre et gagner de l'argent
on devrait faire une alliance allez on
arrête de craquer le slip on se souhaite
à tous une très bonne une bonne journée
je vous aime fort je vous fais plein de
grands bisous c'est la nouvelle phrase
de fin elle est pas allé à bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]